with news that Brad Wright is almost
certainly not going to be involved in a
new Stargate I had to ask the question
how worried are the side trackers and we
got an answer welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV and movie channel
[Music]
so a couple of days ago I put a poll on
the side track channel on the Community
page and I asked you amazing side
Trekkers with Brad Wright confirming
he's not involved in a new Stargate plan
it's time to ask a question will you
give Stargate a chance and watch it if
Brad Wright is not involved in any way
yes if Stargate was one answer no no
Brad no chance maybe depends on the
trailers Etc now I've got the answers to
that poll and we're going to discuss
that in a minute but just to give you a
quick recap on November 5th I released a
video telling you that Brad Wright had
been tweeting that he was not going to
be involved in any Stargate he basically
said it would have been fun and the
script that he produced for MGM has been
Gathering dust there's all new players
involved now and it just doesn't look
like it's going to happen now this
confirmed something I've been telling
you since March that Amazon didn't
really like Brad's script and had no
intention of going ahead with it now MGM
kept pushing for it they pushed for it
right up until the sale was finalized
they were hoping to Greenlight a project
immediately
and they genuinely believed that Amazon
wanted them to do that but as soon as
the sale was finalized the hammer came
down and Amazon have completely changed
Direction now in my next video I'm going
to explain to you a little bit why that
has happened because there are practical
reasons the way Amazon does business
that explains why we're still waiting
for Stargate and also explains why Brad
Wright won't be involved
guys if you like the design this is
available on side ashtrack.com you can
even buy Stargate socks please go and
give it a look also if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
the Bell notification it really helps us
out and if you enjoy the content don't
forget to become a fully fledged side
tracker and hit that join Button as well
as subscribe into sides our sister
Channel all of the links are in the
description but for now let's get back
to what you the amazing subscribers of
Sidetrack answered to those questions so
would you watch Stargate even if Brad
Wright isn't involved yes it's Stargate
57 maybe depends on the trailers and
things 34 percent
but the big question here was no Brad no
chance now I get a lot of comments off
you guys telling me that if Brad Wright
isn't involved in this project they will
not watch it no Brad no chance
but on this vote
402 votes by the way over two days no
brand no chance only got nine percent of
the vote so what do I think about the
results there now I actually think the
57 only just over half of people saying
that they will watch it regardless is a
little lower than I thought I will be
watching this show
I don't care if Brad Wright's involved
or not particularly it's Stargate it's a
project I am desperate to return I 100
will be watching this regardless of
whether Brad Wright's involved or not
you know you can get brilliant
merchandise like this on
skydashtrack.com I don't produce these
things to make money I make originally
no money off them I do it because I want
to keep pushing the agenda that we must
get Stargate back on our screens this is
why I keep talking about Stargate and I
keep pushing as hard as I can but the 34
of people that said it would depend on
the trailers and things I can kind of
understand where they're coming from and
it's it is maybe a slightly pragmatic
approach but at the end of the day we
don't really know what Amazon are going
to do with this project and if they come
back with something that is a hard
reboot
it would make me think twice about it I
will still watch the TV show and I will
judge it upon its merits so I can
understand that approach
but 10 40 people basically that voted on
this poll said they would not give
Stargate any chance at all if Brad isn't
involved regardless of who they get
involved How about if Amanda Tapping was
going to be tapped up as the new
showrunner would they still not watch it
then now these are really thoughtful
subscribers and they've really
considered this opinion and they're
loyal to Brad Wright which is no bad
thing this is the man that co-created
the show we all love and I think we can
all agree if I was to put a poll on
there today saying do you want Brad
involved in some way a hundred percent
of people that love Stargate would say
yes but does that mean we should throw
Stargate away if he's not involved for
me no be a little bit like Battlestar
Galactica fans of the original series
saying that they're not going to watch
the new rebooted series because Ronald D
Moore's doing it now I would argue
actually that what he then did with a
franchise was incredible and he created
a whole new universe that I absolutely
adored I am maybe hopeful maybe naive
that actually if Amazon bring in the
right person somebody to inject a new
Fresh blood into the project we could
get something a new Stargate that is
equally as exciting as the Battlestar
Galactica franchise was when that
returned now
if I'm 100 honest
I'm not massively hopeful but I have to
hold on to hope hope is eternal and I
need that hope
so all I can do is say to you that I am
going to stay positive about this I'm
going to pray that the main reason why
Amazon is taking so damn long to bring
Stargate back is because they're serious
about making it good and they want to
get it right rumors about [ __ ] ghost
Beat and Mark Fergus being brought in to
develop the project really really warm
my fuzzy regions because I think those
are the type of people that are capable
of making a really good show and
producing a show that is loyal to the
original content
but until we have a production company
until we know really who is going to be
running the show we have to have some
trepidation and I can completely
understand why 10 of you are very very
worried
but guys get in the comments and tell me
what you think go and have a look at the
poll and cast your vote if you haven't
already get into the comments and tell
me exactly what you think about the
possibility of no Brad Wright
on a personal note as well if you ever
wonder why do you follow the channel and
why are you a side Trekker I just wanted
to make the very quick point that I put
the video out talking about Brad
Wright's tweets on November the 5th
gateworld put their video out talking
about Brad Wright's tweets on November
the 16th and pop cast a day later
so you're a regular side tracker because
I get the news to you much quicker than
other bigger channels as always please
stay safe I'll see you next time
[Music]